i don't even know anymore about the two
thousand dollar checks
are they coming who's getting them don't
know yet is hilaria baldwin getting two
grand
i hope she does who cares that she wants
to be a hispanic
it makes you interesting it's nice when
someone puts on an accent
i like that being who you are is stupid
truly be another thing
if you're not interesting make yourself
interesting
and she's like she wanted to be like
penelope cruz or
catherine zeta jones or one of them it's
katherine zeta jones spanish
uh let me see well whatever it doesn't
matter let's not lose our [ __ ] minds
here
the point is that she wanted to be a
spanish lady
so what she wanted to be a high-class
immigrant let her let her be it
stop getting mad at her i'm i defend her
i defend her right to envision a
different life
for herself than the one she had she
married the psychopath millionaire
and and she goes it's not good enough
because i go to parties and everyone
goes oh you're just this guy's [ __ ]
i want to be something interesting and
you know those white [ __ ] love as
someone is slightly different
white people love when someone is
slightly different which is what she is
it's slightly different it's not that
different
she's not an ms-13 she's not in la raza
and i'm not equating those two things
i'm just saying she's not selling uh
you know uh mango with paprika in soho
she's slightly different ever so
slightly she's different
she's a few degrees away from a basic
white [ __ ]
let her be it she's not sister soldier
she's just different enough to make
upper-class
white people it's a little spice
it's a little spice i don't see the
problem with it
she's not going all the way here
she's just doing that come on
it's cute it's kind of cute
it's endearing it's cute it makes me
like her more
the commitment to that is is impressive
to me i'm impressed by her that she goes
i just want to be a little she's clearly
not
hispanic at all in any
meaningful way but she just wants to be
a little dick people don't realize how
hard it is to be rich
that's the problem too many people are
focused on like
oh i don't have health insurance my
mom's dad
there's no appreciation for the
struggles of the wealthy in this country
none it's true you know
it did too much focus
on people without and not enough about
people
with hilaria baldwin
is thrust into this world of very
interesting capable intelligent people
and she's got no way to differentiate
herself she's a basic white [ __ ]
she's a live laugh love chardonnay [ __ ]
and she just [ __ ] lucked out
with that alec baldwin who's you know
always you know telling his daughter
she's a pig and
punching photographers and doing a
horrible trump impression by the way
on that horrible show on saturday night
you should watch
this and she meets these people and
they're endlessly fascinating and
they've had distinguished careers in the
arts and politics or whatever
and she just wants to be a smidgen
different just a little different
than a regular white [ __ ] she just
wants to be a little
cool and have people ask her what was it
like in spain what was that like
you're different from we are did you sit
and paint little tiles and make tapas
did you eat the jamon that's what she
wants she wants people to ask her
and she would tell stories probably fake
little stories and me and
my grandmother i must speak to her and
we go to the village and we make
we take the pig and we carve the pig
into the jamon
that's all she wants to do i'm in full
support of her
would it heal the country if the cops
shot her i'mma do the aisle i'ma do
diallo style
like 41 times against saks fifth avenue
perhaps if the cops just shot her 41
times
as she drops her bags at bergdorf
goodman and just empty
emptied into her i mean would people be
happy with that
perhaps but i don't know we don't have
to keep shaming this woman for wanting
to be slightly different
what's the problem i like it go right
back to it i hope she's asian next
how interesting it would be what if one
of your friends just became asian you
wouldn't respect them more
if i had a friend that became asian i
would respect them
so much more than i currently do just
found a way to like
be asian like start looking asian
dressing asian
creating an entire identity as an asian
person saying they
grew up in asia saying they grew up in
japan when it was just
provably untrue that would be your
coolest friend
because you'd be like this person's
asian now i knew her when she was an
asian and that's where we're gonna head
i mean somebody tweeted on twitter the
other day gender is not a big deal
that's why nobody cares about
transgender why we all have to be the
race we're born
let people switch yeah yeah that makes
sense let people be fluid baby let
people be flee you want to be black
you'd be black
you want to you know there's you know
that's a mixed bag
according to black people they'll tell
you it's not all nice
uh but let people be asian
i would like to be another race why why
do i have to be an irish
prick for my entire life this red-faced
irish rant and goblin for my entire
goddamn life
why can't i be castilian spanish i call
him nice white spanish
or why can't i be asian why can't i be
russian i don't understand that and i
think it's a
stupid kind of [ __ ]
outdated thing so i applaud her
and and whatever she wants to do i
support her i think that [ __ ] people get
angry about this [ __ ]
for no goddamn reason i mean
she's just a little different she's not
she's not like walking around trying to
be a maid she's not trying to be a lower
class
person she's trying to be upper she's
still she's not
she's not stabbing her class in the back
here
she's still going to garden parties and
drinking [ __ ] viv
click o she just does it with a little
accent it would be really
uh gross if she like was pretending to
be a maid or something right
because we'd all be like you don't have
to do this [ __ ] it would be really bad
if she was pretending
to do something like that but she's just
putting on a little accent kind of the
way madonna did
it's really not that big of a deal
speaking of maids my maid is as fat and
as lazy as i am
what's the point of having her she come
the other day and i can't she's in here
no mask i don't know where she's been
she's in here the other day in my
kitchen and we're both silently eating a
pumpkin loaf
not no one's cleaning if i want i'm fat
and lazy i don't need another fat and
lazy person
to just stare at me you know i mean i
don't know what to do with this woman i
like her and i tip her and i give her a
lot of money
but she's slow and and she just doesn't
do much she talks on the phone she's on
the phone all the time it's
literally me i'm bringing in another me
to my house
she's on the phone all the time it takes
her forever to go through go through the
house
i'm just i'm importing another version
of myself here
but that's not what hilaria is doing
hilarious cause people ask me to talk
about this they're like
what's your take on it i'm like i think
rich people should be able to pretend to
be
other races i believe that
sorry maybe that's not a popular take
but i believe
it's fun and they should be allowed to
do it and i think many people are going
to disagree with me because they're like
but she's not pretending to be like a
poor oppressed per if she was doing
blackface and had dreads i get it
it would be a little offensive it would
be offensive if she was in full black
face with like a bob marley wig
and she's like hey man watch a dual mat
like i understand that okay
but she's not doing any of that she's
just pretending to be an upper-class
hispanic person
which is just a few degrees to the left
of what she is
which is just a basic white [ __ ]
there's nothing wrong with that i i am
for
the ability of rich people and poor
people if they can pull it off
it's like mark norman has a joke about
transgender people it's like you know
caitlyn jenner can do anything she wants
she's got the money so
if you're poor and you could pull off
being another race good for you
but rich people should be able
to to try on another uh
country's history if they so choose
i don't see a problem with it i don't
see any problem it doesn't bother me at
all
i would love someone if in the middle of
a thick russian accent they whispered to
me goes
listen i decided to be russian three
years ago i'm not russian
i decided to be russian three years ago
and i came up with this whole back story
and it's just fine life is too short to
enforce these rigid
roles on people it's crazy many of you
are offended by it because it's you why
don't you cook up something good
you figure out how to do something you
know